The restaurant industry is being challenged. Unlike others, you know,
there's many States where tipped employees get paid about two 20 an hour,
and it's an employee tip credit of, you know, whatever it is,
$13 an hour to adjust their payroll down. So these employees typically make 20,
30, $40 an hour in tips in many of these places. So they make two 20 now.
And payroll from two 20,
an hour to $15 is a 600% payroll
increase.
There is no business in a world that can sustain a 600% payroll increase.
So I'm trying to protect my industry.
I'm trying to protect the people that work in the industry by creating a stable
economic model. So there is no guilt and stability.
[Inaudible].
That small businesses, the guy that just wants to make a great bar,
a great restaurant, not, not a franchise, not a big business,
but the guy that wants in his hometown to just put the greatest restaurant ever
there,
that they will have looked at what happened over the last year and be like,
you know what? The risks, risks always. I'm sure you know,
the numbers for restaurants and bars.
If you want to tell everybody the failure rates, they're always absurdly high,
but now the risks seem almost incalculably high for people to want to get in on
this.
You know, it's interesting that you mentioned,
I own a franchise called Taphorn Tavern and we created this franchise.
You'll find this interesting, and I'm not doing this as a plug. We, we,
two years ago had no way rapport. We were approaching $15 minimum wages.
And the labor pool that we did have were mostly new Americans who didn't speak
English so well. So I said,
I got to create the casual dining concept of the future.
So I want to cut labor costs in half. I want to bring in robotic cooking,
robotic ovens, eliminate back of the house, uh,
create this whole new restaurant model. So I did,
I worked with companies like Middleby and worked in test kitchens around the
country and created this kitchen of the future concept a year ago,
created called Peffers Tavern.
Did our franchise registration started the franchise COVID happens.
We find out we don't have any raw protein in our restaurant.
It's all Suvi cooking. Everything is individually wrapped, prepared,
and computerized ovens. It's really high quality.
So we don't have raw and cooked product. We don't have Greece,
we don't even have hoods. So we have a very different cooking model. It,
it is the kitchen of the future.
We are the most COVID safe kitchen in the world.
We didn't even design it this way. So now we put uniforms on our kitchen staff.
We have cameras in the kitchen,
so you can see your food be prepared right on your phone.
And we created the safest cleanest kitchen concept in the country,
starting on a whole different basis.
So I watch my franchises and I'm answering your question for you,
cause this is interesting. They haven't, we sold a bunch of franchises.
We sold Washington. We sold the Atlanta.
A whole bunch of territories would do it very, very well.
The franchise is going COVID hits shoe sales,
stop a franchises about 45 days later,
we get a phone call from some people that say, listen,
we're a franchise company. We're interested in buying your franchise.
And here's why we want to buy it now because we think some of the greatest
restaurant locations in America are going to become available in the next 90
days.
And we want to jump on those locations with a concept that has good,
solid economic modeling. And, you know, it's an interesting,
I never quite thought that way. So we just sold the city of Boston.
We just sold the city of Washington,
DC to sophisticated developers who are now dropping them in places like Faneuil
hall. Cause these locations have become available.
My point is this there's opportunity now,
and the industry is going to go through a shift. There's no question about it,
but there's great locations that are going to be available.
Now there's aggressive landlords who will give you a very aggressive deals right
now with 10 and allow in packages and free read for a year or two. I mean,
they will bend over backwards to do those deals.
So to that fictitious restaurant guy that we were just talking about,
who's scared to do it. Maybe this is the time to do it.
And I put a fascinating thought model out there.
Now we have a big to go element that we've put in,
in tappers Tavern and a curbside element.
So we shifted the business model post COVID, obviously Dave,
but my point is this. If you've ever wanted to be in a restaurant business,
one of the highest costs we got is occupancy and construction today.
There's unbelievable opportunity out there.
Don't just think that COVID is bad for the industry.
It could be good for the industry to, uh, for some people in the end.
Yeah. Interesting chaos. Yeah. Well, chaos always brings opportunity.
I'm actually glad you brought up the automated kitchen and mentioned a little
bit about the economics of some of this,
because it is something that I talk about a lot on the show relative to minimum
wage and the rest of it. So for you as a guy that won,
I know you want to employ people.
You want people to feel empowered and feel like they have some control in their
lives and all that when you're making those decisions to go, well,
wait a minute,
I can't pay these people $15 an hour because technically they're not worth it.
If they don't speak the language and all that without getting into all the
specifics of that. D D do you have sort of like a,
almost like a philosophical struggle there between how to go ahead and do a new
business that isn't going to hire as many people potentially. Uh,
but he's going to be more of say a restaurant of the future and,
and something that's sustainable. That's your, that's your whole point.
Yeah, honestly, no. Uh, and of course there's a personal fact.
You want to hire as many people as you can. You know,
my proudest day is when I had about 900 employees and I used to sit,
think to myself every night I put about a thousand meals on the table every day.
I was really proud of that. But you know,
today my responsibility is sustain the jobs of the people that work for me to
provide them with an opportunity that is consistent is going to last and provide
them with a good income. Bigger.
It doesn't necessarily mean more stable doesn't mean more income for everyone
also. There's what about the guy who built all the robotics,
who programmed all the systems, they got jobs that didn't have them before.
So I don't think I'm eliminating jobs.
I think I'm redistributing those jobs a little bit into technology plays rather
than just straight cook lines. But, but, you know,
I think that the restaurant industry is being challenged. Unlike others.
You know,
there's many States where tipped employees get paid about two 20 an hour,
and it's an employee tip credit of, you know, whatever it is,
$13 an hour to adjust your payroll down. So these employees typically make 20,
30, $40 an hour in tips in many of these places. So they make two 20 now.
And payroll from two 20,
an hour to $15 is a 600% payroll
increase.
There is no business in a world that can sustain a 600% payroll increase.
So I'm trying to protect my industry.
I'm trying to protect the people that work in the industry by creating a stable
economic model. So there is no guilt and stability.
There is no guilt and following, you know,
economic models that provide prosperity for those who work for us. So, uh, it,
isn't my choice. I'd much rather be hiring more people,
but it isn't something I have any guilt about.
Yeah. I, I love the answer. I mean that, that's the honest answer.
And unfortunately we've got a lot of business owners these days that would give
you the guilt answer, uh,
to just sort of pretend they're doing the right thing as opposed to actually
actually doing the right thing. Um, if somebody,
if somebody is watching this right now and they're young and they always wanted
to get into the biz, um, you know, you talked about a,
a long resume of doing basically everything. What would you recommend? I mean,
is, is the first job just to be a bar back or,
or do you have like a specific idea on how they get in on this?
Yeah. You know,
I think the most important two jobs are wine cook and a bar back,
you are in everything from those two positions are bartender. So, you know,
I'm of the belief that,
that you should not go into this business until you at least 10 bar and work in
a kitchen. Uh, those are the two areas where waste occurs.
Those are the two areas with theft occurs. Those are the two hearts of the,
of the business. If it breaks down there. And either of those places,
you have no business. Uh,
the worst thing in the world in a restaurant industry is to be held hostage to
ignorance.
I can't tell you how many friends I've had over the years that have opened
restaurants that have never been in a business before they hire a chef, right?
They pay them X amount of dollars a year. They're open 60 days. The chef says,
this is all on me. I won equity or I'm leaving.
And the guy who owns it doesn't know how to cook a steak,
or doesn't even know one of his own recipes. He's held hostage by his ignorance.
This is a challenging business, you know, think of, of a retail store,
but the t-shirts go bad after three days. How about that?
Imagine a t-shirt shop that they right away after three or four days, you know,
th th th that the staff that we have to manage production,
we have to manage retail, manage merchandising, manage staff, manage purchasing.
It's a very difficult business and you can't do it from a point of ignorance.
Those are the people who fail. And it's interesting day,
because if you look at the statistics about one of eight succeed for first-time
operator, seven of eight succeed for the second time,
wow. It's a fascinating shift in the statistics.
So once you made those mistakes, the first time, they've just sort of ready now,
but without the experience,
you're not in a very good statistical place with the experience you're in a far
better statistical place.
What resources can we send people to? Are you still doing seminars on?
Oh, sure. Yeah, sure. We still do seminars. You can go to Jon taffer.com.
Matter of fact,
we're working on an industry webinar in the next couple of weeks,
so you can go visit Jon taffer.com. You know,
there's great resources out there for restaurant people,
please go to the national restaurant association site.
They have wonderful COVID information, great marketing programs and such.
There's another organization, a nightclub and bar show and media group,
which also has great information on it. And then of course, you know,
we have our TVT,
which is about 40 hours of training content marketing promotion that we have
that's available on our website. Also, my point is this, you know,
when this pandemic started and I'd like to sort of be positive here for a
minute, Dave, you know, when this pandemic started, I saw people get paralyzed.
They didn't know what to do. They were frozen. You know,
my second book about excuses, which we talked about, you know,
I realized that at this time, great marketers are going to bubble to the top.
Aren't they we're going to see some amazing stuff.
Great promoters are going to bubble to the top.
We're going to see great activations and programs and online events and great
operators are going to bubble to the top.
We're going to see incredible things happen out there.
So this is a time to mobilize, not parallel.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.